Imagine the smartest person in the entire world has this incredibly profound secret to tell you.
A life-altering truth, yeah.
Exactly.
But before they speak a single word to you, they make you walk away from the crowds.
Leave it all behind.
You walk completely out of the bustling city.
You go past the very last houses, out into a graveyard.
Just absolute silence.
There's the silent tombs.
And they wait until the only things surrounding you are the dead.
Only then do they deliver their gravest, most important counsel.
Sets a mood, doesn't it?
Really does.
Welcome to this deep dive.
Today we are opening Reza Shakazemi's spiritual ethos.
And we are exploring this really intense frontier.
The boundary line, essentially.
Yeah, the exact boundary where human thinking just, well, it exhausts its standard tools and something entirely different has to take over.
It's a difficult transition to talk about.
It is.
We are looking at why the most exalted speech about God is built almost entirely out of denials and at the same time, why the human intellect must ultimately be lived out in a perpetual war against one's own soul.
Which sounds completely contradictory at first glance.
Totally.
But to guide us, we have this single organizing reality that will anchor our whole conversation today.
It goes like this.
The intellect is a living spiritual faculty realized only through the war to win the whole soul over to its side.
It is such a bracing place to start.
Oh, definitely.
Because it throws us immediately into a profound crisis of perception.
To understand what actually happens at that frontier of the mind, we really have to sit with those two distinct puzzles you just mentioned.
The speech and the graveyard.
Yes.
The first puzzle is structural.
How is it that the most precise soaring speech ever uttered about the divine operates by stripping away our words?
Just taking them apart.
Exactly.
It is this patient, unyielding litany of what God is not.
And then the second puzzle is the setting itself.
Why does the wisest man of his age require the mute company of the graveyard before delivering his teaching?
Like why go to those extremes?
Right.
I mean we really have to feel the sheer stakes of these mysteries before we attempt any answers at all because they are both asking the exact same fundamental question.
Which is what?
Does it truly take to break through the reasoning surface of the mind and actually access the deeper perception that the intellect is built for?
So to explore this, we're looking really closely at the language and the life of Ali, peace be upon him.
When we look at how he speaks of the divine, there is this honest, almost
I don't know, uncomfortable tension between the spiritual depths of the intellect and its rational surface.
Uncomfortable is a good word for it.
And the book insists we have to start at that rational surface.
We can't just bypass it.
Oh, absolutely not.
The mind has to begin with concepts.
We use words like mercy, power, nearness, reality.
Basics.
The basics, yes.
The intellect really has no other equipment to set out on the journey.
So you can't just throw out logic on day one.
No, to reject concepts or despise the rational
logical surface of the mind as somehow unspiritual.
That is a massive mistake.
The revelation given by the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, provides the mind with these exact concepts.
They give us a place to stand.
They're the initial footholds.
But then we hit the discontinuity.
We hit the absolute boundary of what language can actually do.
And this brings us to this foundational concept in the text regarding how human language functions.
We need to look at the idea of definition.
Yes.
The Arabic understanding of definition is highly instructive here because it carries a dual mechanism.
Meaning it does two things at once.
Exactly.
A definition is the act of fixing what a concept is, but crucially it also means a limit.
Like a physical edge.
Yes.
To define a thing is to literally draw an edge around it.
This is our first governing analogy here.
Definition as a drawn edge.
Okay, I can picture that.
Bounding is what makes a concept functional in our daily lives.
I mean, if you define a physical object, you draw a conceptual boundary around it so you can distinguish it from something else.
So drawing the edge separates this from that.
It creates a useful limitation so we can actually talk about things.
Precisely.
But consider the mechanical failure that occurs when the reality you are seeking is, by its very nature, limitless.
Because it doesn't have an edge.
Exactly.
When you attempt to define the limitless, every single act of definition, no matter how careful or reverent you are of being, misses the mark by its own success.
Oh, because the very act of drawing the edge creates a boundary that the limitless reality instantly outruns.
Yes.
The concept fixes a shape, but God has no shape.
Therefore, going beyond the limits set by rational definition requires a faculty that operates beyond reason.
Not against it.
Beyond its edges, yes.
Okay, I have to stop you there.
I don't buy that yet if every concept of God is negated, what is left to worship?
That reaction is completely natural.
It is exactly the panic the rationalist mind feels when its primary tools are taken away.
It feels like jumping into a void.
It does.
But the defense against that panic is understanding the sharp difference between a strictly rationalistic view and a truly spiritual view.
How do they differ?
Well, rationalism treats reason as the entirety of existence.
If a reality eludes clear, bounded concepts,
The rationalist dismisses it as unreal, or like you said, as a void.
Because they can't draw an edge around it.
Exactly.
The spiritual view, however, keeps the net of reason gladly, but it knows the largest realities will always slip through the mesh.
So the danger is mistaking our own mental boundaries for the boundaries of reality itself.
You hit the nail on the head.
If you equate your personal logical reasoning with the totality of the intellect, you shrink the vast objective reality of revelation down to the private specific
of your own brain.
You make God small enough to fit in your head.
Yes.
Reason initiates the movement toward truth.
It simply cannot complete it.
The surface of the intellect is real and it is useful, but the ground beneath it goes down infinitely further.
And what's down there?
Like what faculty takes over when reason hits its drawn edge.
The heart.
Okay, and the text makes a really critical distinction here.
We are not talking about the heart as the seat of emotion or sentiment.
No, not at all.
use the word today for feelings.
We are talking about an organ of profound perception.
We must distinguish carefully between outward sight and inner vision.
Outward sight is the ordinary mechanical faculty of the physical eyes.
Inner vision is a spiritual perception lit by the verities of faith.
Verities of faith.
What does that mean in this context?
These are deep structural realities disclosed to someone who believes, opening a capacity in the heart to perceive what no physical eye could ever process.
Ali was actually asked a direct question about this, wasn't he?
Was.
A man asked him if he had ever seen his Lord, and his answer just forces us to completely reevaluate what seeing actually means.
He said that eyes do not see him through the observation proper to sight, but hearts see him through the verities of faith.
The precision of his answer is so vital.
He decisively rules out the physical eyes, because God is not an object in the physical universe possessing edges that light can strike.
Right, I mean, yeah, you can't bounce photons off the divine.
Exactly.
But notice he does not retreat into mere poetry.
He affirms a genuine literal seeing.
He simply relocates the mechanism to its proper faculty.
The heart.
And scripture backs this up entirely, asserting that it is not the eyes that grow blind, but the hearts within the breasts that grow blind.
That is a terrifying thought.
It is, because if you have perfectly functioning physical eyes, but your inner eye is dark,
So we arrive back at that threshold.
Reason has drawn its edge.
It can go no further.
The heart has to take over the work of perception.
But how does a mind, which has been heavily trained to rely only on bounded concepts its whole life, actually cross that boundary?
Like how do we transition from thinking about a truth to perceiving it directly?
It is carried across by paradox.
In this spiritual ethos, paradox is not a rhetorical flourish.
It is a vital working mechanism.
How does it work?
Because there is an unbridgeable gap between reality as it is in itself and the tiny human concepts we form of it, that gap has to be felt by the seeker.
It cannot just be stated as a dry fact.
So paradox is the tool.
Paradox is the instrument designed to make you feel the failure of the concept.
This is apophatic discourse then.
Speech that precedes by unsaying.
Yes, is the deliberate architecture of affirming an attribute and immediately denying the boundary of that attribute.
attribute.
You have to take the human conception of reality apart, piece by piece.
It sounds destructive.
It's an unbuilding.
A negation clears the ground.
It creates a vast empty space where a deeper inner vision can finally rise.
We see the absolute summit of this with the Prophet.
We do.
In the physical posture of prostration, placing the highest part of the human head onto the lowest dust of the earth, he reached a height of spiritual nearness.
where he admitted his total inability to capture the divine in words.
He said, I cannot enumerate your praise.
You are as you have praised yourself.
The admission of failure is the highest praise.
Because the reality forever outruns the word sent after it.
Ali takes this foundation and builds an incredible structure of paradox upon it.
We find this in his collected sermons, the peak of eloquence.
The opening of the very first sermon in that collection executes this perfectly.
It begins by offering praise,
does so by immediately confessing that all praise falls short.
Yeah, that no speech, no human reckoning can possibly deliver what is actually owed.
And then it introduces this organizing reality.
It says the divine attribute has no binding limitation, no existing description.
It is such a difficult phrase to sit with.
The attributes say mercy or power is affirmed as absolutely real.
Yet in the exact same breath, it is declared to have no existing description.
It's pulling the rug out from under your conceptual mind.
And then the sermon constructs this ladder of realization, says the foremost thing in religion is the knowledge of God.
Yes.
The perfection of that knowledge is belief.
The perfection of belief is affirming oneness.
And the perfection of oneness is sincerity.
And then comes the shock that dismantles the mind's comfort.
The perfection of that sincerity is to divest God of the attributes.
You climb this ladder, affirming on one rung, only to negate on the next.
The text gives you the words to approach the divine and then ruthlessly strips those very words away so you cannot turn them into idols.
Okay, but that sounds like wordplay isn't affirming and denying 1 attribute a contradiction?
It looks like a contradiction to the reasoning mind, sure, but it is actually a highly engineered jolt.
A jolt.
Yes.
To understand the mechanics of it, look at the pattern of the first testimony of Islam.
it pairs a stark negation with an absolute affirmation.
First, the denial, there is no God, then the exception, except God.
So the negation removes the false limit.
Exactly.
What is being destroyed is not the attribute of mercy or justice itself.
but the human limitation that clings to our conception of it.
Okay, I think I see.
When we conceptualize mercy, we make it a bounded thing.
We draw an edge around it.
We do.
We make it separate from justice.
We make it separate from the essence of God.
But the attribute in its reality is entirely one with the essence.
Yes.
So the spiritual meaning of mercy is kept, but the boundary the mind drew around it dissolves.
The shock of the contradiction proves to the seeker that their mental portrait of the absolute is flat, forcing them to look for the depth.
It forces the heart to open.
A later poet captured this emptying beautifully.
He described it as a ladder of ascent.
Dying is mineral to become plant.
Dying is plant to rise to animal.
Dying is animal to become human.
So every time you let go of a bounded smaller self, you move upward.
The emptying leaves you with the fullness of reality.
If the intellect has to transcend the reasoning faculty in this dramatic way, we have to look at where the intellect comes from in the 1st place.
The sermon collection shifts from these dizzying heights of paradox down to the very mud of human creation.
This is our second governing analogy.
The spirit breathed into clay.
It's a very grounded image after all that abstract theology.
It is.
The sermon unfolds the creation of the human being in a slow, deliberate scene.
The creator gathers earth hard and soft, sweet and salty.
Water is worked into it.
Kneaded and shaped.
Kneaded and shaped into a form with joints and limbs.
It is hardened until it rings like sounding clay.
If you picture that perfectly finished biological form, it has eyes, it has ears, the physical organ of the brain is entirely set within the skull.
Nothing is structurally missing.
And yet it's just sounding clay.
It can neither see nor hear nor think.
It is only when the spirit is breathed into it that the form stands up
as a living human being endowed with the power to reflect and with knowledge to tell true from false.
So the biological organs did not generate the life or the consciousness.
No.
The life was breathed into the organs.
It is literally an inspiration.
The single breath produces both life and intellect in the exact same instant.
So the capacity to think is not an accessory bolted onto an animal frame later on.
Never.
The bestowal of the spirit is the bestowal of consciousness.
This is why treating the intellect as just a data processing machine is a total failure to understand what it is.
To be true to the intellect is exactly the same thing as being spiritual.
And that profound unity defines what the tradition calls the true.
Which is very different from our modern definition.
Yeah, today we think an intellectual is someone who retains a lot of information or wins debates on TV.
But the true intellectual is the one who puts each thing in its proper place.
Which is the exact definition of justice?
Yes.
Only the true intellectual can be fully just because only the one who perceives reality without the distortion of their own ego can set things where they truly belong.
Right thought, right action, and the realization of the real are one single unified faculty.
They cannot be separated.
But if that is the standard for the true intellectual, we have to face the terrifying question of what it actually costs to become such a person.
The price is deep.
What does it demand of a human life?
And this is where we reach the pivot of the entire teaching.
We have to follow Ali on a walk into the graveyard.
The setting is entirely deliberate.
The commander of the faithful takes his student, the disciple Kumail ibn Ziyad, by the hand.
Just the two of them.
They leave Kufa.
They walk until the markets, the noise, and the living city are entirely left behind.
They walk out among the mute company of the dead.
Why there?
You wait for this isolation because
The teaching he's about to deliver dismantles the entire value system of the city they just left.
Surrounded by tombs, he tells his disciple that hearts are vessels and the best of them hold the most.
And then he ruthlessly sorts all of humanity into 3 categories.
The sorting is uncompromising.
He says there is the lordly knower anchored securely in the Lord.
There's the seeker pursuing knowledge for deliverance.
And then there is the common crowd.
The drifting crowd.
The text likens this third group to moths hurling themselves blindly into any flickering flame, drifting with every passing current, seeking no firm support.
To save his disciple from becoming a moth drifting on the winds of circumstance.
He draws this incredible contrast between knowledge and wealth across 5 specific dimensions.
He dissects exactly why the city's priorities are backwards.
Let's look at them.
First, he points out the burden of security.
Knowledge stands guard over you, whereas you must spend your life energy standing guard over your wealth.
The mental bandwidth required just to protect assets is immense.
Wealth requires a fortress.
It makes you a prisoner of your own money.
But inner knowledge is a fortress.
It secures your character for making destructive choices.
Exactly.
The second dimension is the law of increase.
Wealth decreases every time you spend it.
is a zero-sum game.
You hand over a coin, you don't have the coin anymore.
But knowledge actively grows the more freely it is dispersed.
When you empty your mind to teach another person, you are forced to clarify your own understanding, which deepens your grasp of the truth.
The third dimension deals with longevity.
The fruits of wealth vanish the moment the money is gone.
The status, the comforts, the fair-weather allies.
They evaporate instantly.
But no turn of fortune, no economic collapse can strip a human being of their inner knowledge.
It remains permanently intact.
The 4th dimension fundamentally changes how we view intelligence.
He says the acquisition of knowledge is a religion, a debt repaid to the maker.
A debt.
The intellect is not your private property to use for your own amusement.
It is a profound gift breathed into your clay, and the use of it to seek truth is the repayment of a cosmic debt.
And the 5th dimension is about command.
Knowledge is a judge that actively directs your life.
Wealth is just a passive thing that is continually judged, managed, and disposed of.
Knowledge is the active force.
Wealth is merely a material tool.
He concludes this comparison by stating that those who hoard wealth perish while they are still breathing, but true knowers endure as long as time endures.
But even as he delivers the soaring praise of knowledge, he presses his hand to his chest and mourns.
The grief is palpable in the text.
He mourns the absolute lack of worthy vessels to carry this truth.
He lists the broken vessels he sees around him.
Who does he see?
The student who is sharp but untrustworthy, who weaponizes religion for personal gain.
The blindly obedient follower whose faith shatters at the first sign of doubt because they have no inner insight.
The person greedy for pleasure, led by their appetites, the hoarder.
He is entirely surrounded by people, yet profoundly isolated.
But the council shifts into a prayer.
He declares that the earth will never be left empty of a hidden few who uphold the proof of God.
They might be the smallest in number, but they hold the greatest rank.
The present imam of the time echoes this, reminding us that knowledge is a trust.
debt discharged solely by giving it away.
These hidden few are not just librarians preserving historical facts.
They are the living channels through which reality anchors the earth.
And here we reach the most critical sentence of the Graveyard Council.
Ali says that through them, knowledge penetrates the reality of insight.
The verb is key.
Yes, the verb used for penetrates brings us to our third governing analogy.
The army storming the commander.
The word implies a violent strategic assault.
How so?
Think of ancient warfare.
An army is structured with a right wing, a left wing, and a center.
At the absolute center stands the commander.
Giving the orders.
The objective of an assault is to smash through the flanks, ignore the distractions on the wings, and drive a wedge straight into the heart of the enemy line to capture the commander.
And once you take the commander.
You possess the entire field.
The battle is won.
So knowledge is not just data sitting on a page.
It contains
a latent explosive force.
The student has to wage an effortful assault to storm past the outer wall of concepts.
And when that knowledge finally breaks through and seizes the heart, it takes the command of the limbs, the thoughts, and the actions, exactly as a victorious general takes command of a conquered kingdom.
The interiorization is total.
There is no seam left between what they know and what they are.
This requires an immense exertion, which brings us directly to our central spine.
Let's hear it.
The intellect is a living spiritual faculty realized only through the war to win the whole soul over to its side.
The realization of the intellect demands the absolute orientation of the soul.
And you cannot orient the soul toward reality if it is clogged with vice.
No, you cannot.
In this vision, vice is not just bad manners.
It is a metaphysical obstruction.
It is a rust that spreads across the perceptive surface of the heart.
If the heart is the organ capable of seeing the verities of faith,
then vice actively blinds that inner eye.
Therefore, the true intellectual is in a state of perpetual war.
Uprooting ignorance and dissolving vice are the exact same act.
You cannot see reality clearly if your ego is constantly distorting the lens.
Wait, this seems grim.
If the struggle is against the soul, isn't the soul the enemy?
Are we talking about destroying our own selves?
That is the most dangerous misunderstanding of this entire tradition.
How so?
It is not a war against the soul.
It is a war for the soul.
To understand
The terrain.
Picture 3 figures standing on a battlefield.
On one side, you have the intellect leading the forces of the compassionate.
On the opposing side, you have caprice, human whim, ego, appetite, commanding the forces of the devil.
And the soul sits in the middle.
Exactly.
The soul is the prize.
It is being pulled by caprice on one side and the intellect on the other.
The goal of the intellectual is not to destroy the soul.
The goal is to break the tyrannical grip of caprice
liberate the soul, and enlist it entirely on the side of the intellect.
Okay, I see the difference.
It's a rescue mission, not a search and destroy.
You're winning the soul over, not annihilating it.
Precisely.
You are rescuing the soul from hidden idolatry.
Caprice is the ego setting itself up as a false god.
Sneaky.
Very.
The text describes this hidden idolatry as being more concealed than a black ant crawling across a dark stone on a moonless night.
Almost impossible to see.
Because the ego is setting itself up as the center of the universe, you cannot defeat the ego using the tools of the ego.
You need the higher force of the intellect to break its hold.
And the foundation of this rescue mission is the principle of tawhid.
Yes.
We usually translate tawhid as oneness, treating it as a static noun, like a fact you just memorized.
Like a piece of trivia.
Yeah, but it is a verbal noun.
It is an action.
It means affirming the one, yes, but it fundamentally means making one.
It is the active integration of the self.
A scattered, fragmented soul cannot mirror the one.
If your desire for comfort is pulling you one way, your fear of other people's opinions is pulling you another way, and your ambition is pulling you a third way, your soul is divided.
At war with itself.
Tohed is the painful, necessary work of bringing all of those scattered desires under a single, unified orientation toward the real.
Ali summarizes this integration in four staggering sayings of freedom.
He who knows God integrates himself.
He who knows his own soul disengages himself from its lower whims.
He who knows people isolates himself from their drifting currents.
He who knows the world withholds himself from its traps.
That level of integration requires pure sincerity.
Every single action must be oriented perfectly toward the divine, unadulterated by any foreign motive.
Especially the motive of making yourself look good.
Exactly.
A Sufi master captured this, tying it directly back to our analogy of the breath and the sounding clay.
He taught that human deeds are but lifeless forms.
Their living spirit is the presence of the secret of sincerity breathed into them.
A deed performed without sincerity, even if it looks like a good deed on the outside, is just sounding clay.
It is structurally perfect, but it is dead.
Sincerity is the in-breathing that lifts a mechanical action into life.
The person who achieves this victory over their own ego attains the rank of the true martyr.
They bear witness to reality by sacrificing their own false centrality.
Which brings us to the ultimate stakes of all this exertion.
It is easy to look at this vast battlefield, the paradoxes that strip our words, the emptying of the mind, the stark council among the graves, the army storming the heart, the perpetual war against Caprice, and conclude that this is a grim, exhausting process of endless subtraction.
It sounds like a lot to lose.
That feeling of grim subtraction is just the illusion of the ego panicking.
What is actually being taken away on this battlefield?
Only the false self.
Only the rust on the heart.
Only the idol of caprice that kept you blind.
When you strip away the ego that hijacked the soul, what is uncovered is not a barren wasteland.
What is uncovered is the pure capacity to see reality exactly as it is and the freedom to live in total harmony with it.
And that clear sight.
is the beginning of joy.
The one who has rescued their soul, who has integrated it under the intellect, arrives at a fullness and a blinding beauty that makes all the fleeting, flickering pleasures of the world look like faint shadows.
The war, with all its severity, was only ever fought to make room for this joy.
Which leaves us exactly where we began with the central spine of the teaching.
The intellect is a living spiritual faculty realized only through the war to win the whole soul over to its side.
We turn this back to you listening.
The battlefield we have been describing is not historical.
It is interior and it is active right now.
Look at the terrain of your own life this past week.
Which caprice, which hidden egoistic whim have you allowed to take command of the center of your fields?
And what would it
actually cost you to wage the war, to win your soul back, not to destroy it, but to finally rescue it.